thanks for tuning in to another episode
of sex ed and a big thank you to our
sponsor
manscape if you're looking for a last
minute valentine's day gift make sure to
check out the perfect
package 3.0 which has everything you see
here
it comes with the crop preserver ball
deodorant the crop reviver ball toner
a pair of moisture-wicking boxer briefs
and of course the lawnmower
3.0 which over 2 million men rely on for
all their down their
grooming needs and if you really want to
go big this valentine's day check out
manscaped refined cologne it smells like
a sexy forest i don't know else how to
say it go over to manscape.com
jubilee and you'll get 20 off plus free
shipping thanks for watching
have you ever developed fillings for a
co-star or
hooked up after feel like
yes the tea is hot
[Applause]
[Music]
how many people have you had sex with do
you know the number
oh sh no over 100 people i think
i mean i guess it's not a lot is it i
don't know
i've lost all perspective um i have a
list in my phone
okay the number right now is at 69. i'm
sorry guys i have no idea
at first i was like all proud but now
i'm ashamed to say that
because you have sex so much you'll
literally walk to a person be like hey
nice to meet you and they're like
no we had sex last week and then you
were like oh
i'm so sorry how different is your
personal sex life
from your on camera sex life
my sex life off camera is definitely
more
intimate like i can actually touch them
and feel them on my chest and everything
we don't have to
worry about letting the camera see all
the action
of course you enjoy the sex and you want
to enjoy the sex but at the end of the
day it's all a performance 90
of the things i do on camera i do not
want to do in my room i'm not like
swinging off of a tarzan vine and
backflipping onto him or anything like
that
if something feels good and like you
feel like you want to finish you can
if you're filming it's like wait we
still have two more positions to do
i'm kind of having sex backwards i'm
opening up for angles so you guys can
see the light
and the camera guy can see what's going
on you're not
in a private personal setting my sex
life
is a much more intimate life i think
it's more of a feeling than it is what
you actually
see being able to cry maybe during sex
or maybe even just feeling very
vulnerable during sex i don't
necessarily go to that space a lot
within my pornography because i'm not
sure people actually want to see that
most people just want to see sex you'll
have good
sex on set but you don't get to really
build it up to the point that
you're getting to really know a person
intimately like you get to go out you
get to have drinks you get to eat with a
person
you get to get to know them that's the
fun part that's the experience and then
eventually if this is the difference if
you want to have sex you can
how has your job affected your sex life
has it ruined it um no
i feel like my job gave me like super
powers because of my job i'm super open
so i feel like it's easier to get to
that point in their relationship of like
breaking down all those sexual barriers
and just
jumping into the fun stuff in the
beginning of my career
i kind of got in this mindset where i
was like if i'm not getting paid to have
sex
i'm not doing it this is my job i am now
professional and when you do something
professional
you're getting paid for it forever and
then i fell in love
well um this isn't very
expected of most people but i'm actually
asexual
so i don't have much of a sex life in
general it's like your partner liking
football and you not so you'll go to a
football game with them occasionally but
it's not like you're going to be going
to football games by yourself or all the
time
it was a really big decision to come out
as asexual that immediately can
drop your amount of subscribers or
followers i mean the entire
idea of the adult industry is to
construct a fantasy
and that fantasy is destroyed when you
tell people you aren't sexually
interested in
them i'm starting to believe now i'm
asexual because i don't want to have sex
with anybody at this
point i think i'm starting to become
numb i i i don't know what to tell you
but
um when i entered in the sex industry i
was 18
and i first started off as an escort i
was having like sex with almost six guys
a day
and now that i'm 23 i feel like i've hit
a wall
when it comes to sex it just it takes a
lot to get me
horny um and i think that has a lot to
do with me seeing so many sex partners
when i was younger so yeah
i think i think that's what it is how
often is the sex on screen actually
pleasurable for you
are the orgasms real it was really rare
and i couldn't even tell you the scenes
that i actually did because
i was so focused on performing to be
honest
i would probably say 40 percent
i thought you were supposed to fake it
so i would just go in there and be like
wow tomato i don't know
how i want to answer this is yes yes yes
as a porn consumer
i notice when people aren't connecting
and that doesn't turn me on
so for me my co-star whoever i'm working
with we have to have a sexual connection
i would say almost every single one of
my scenes i have actually had a real
orgasm
i'm not gonna bring you on set and not
orgasm i'm not wasting that time
of course i'm a guy so we have to really
orgasm or else we don't get paid
if you can't finish then they'll fake it
for you so it'd be like
a tube and you would like shoot out like
fake
every shoot like i've ever done like at
least one point we had to like stop
eat something or like drink water or
like something to like get us back in
the spirits
do you watch porn now for pleasure or
does it feel like work i'm
a full-on porn consumer
[Laughter]
now that we have covet i'm just kidding
but actually first of all it can't be a
studio porn like if i know that browsers
or evil angel did it i'm not watching it
so it has to be amateur i have to
believe
that it was real it's funny that you
asked
the only reason why i don't watch porn
is because i'm asexual i just
don't have any particular interest in it
my co-stars
um they're great looking people but i
don't know i feel
weird watching them have sex i'm like i
gotta
film with this person tomorrow i just
had coffee with this person
it's kind of like watching your cousin
have sex like you don't want to watch
your cousin
i'll be watching a porn and i'm really
judgmental on the guys i'm like what's
he doing he's not opening up i can't see
what's going on i'm gonna change this
video this guy's not opening up
do you ever re-watch your own i rewatch
my own scenes to critique myself
and that is it for pleasure i usually
watch my own because i remember the
sensation and the feeling
yeah yeah i do but it's kind of weird
like i'm watching them to make sure that
i did good
like viewable for people trying to
get their jollies off how do you protect
yourself from stis
and pregnancy i know girls who
are just on birth control and i know
girls who are not on birth control
and they just don't shoot when they're
ovulating we get tested
so often every 14 days and then
sometimes it's like more frequently than
every 14 days
not to say that we don't catch the
couple little
bacterial infections here and there it's
kind of part of the job but we try to be
very careful with it my sets are
only safe sex so i'm condom only we
clean our sets we i mean i've been to
sets that are pretty scary
i'm not gonna lie to you but sets i use
and where i shoot we always make sure
everything is clean we make sure
everything is comfortable
have you ever developed fillings for a
co-star
or hooked up after feel like
yes the tea is hot the majority of the
people are pretty hot
so it's hard not to yeah i was actually
the first guy that i filmed with
so i had like this huge crush on him i
was just
amazed by the way he um he threw it on
me
i have seen problems happen between part
oh yes jealousy i've seen it happen
if the partner isn't shooting with their
own partner or all of a sudden the other
partner who's in porn doesn't want the
other partner to do porn anymore
probably not my job is a full-time job
and it's a real relief
to be able to be with someone that takes
me away from that a little
what's the worst part of the job i
always tell this to people i wouldn't
change anything about my job i would
change the way
people in society view my job i know
girls who
just got a brand new apartment and moved
in there and they found out what they
did their neighbors
and then they like send their pictures
to everybody in the complex and be like
oh this girl does porn
make sure you watch out for her like
stuff like that really does happen
the mainstream in the world hates
pornography
and i'm not sure if we'll ever be
accepted and also the fact that i'm a
man who has a vagina so that's a whole
other level
but what i do is i fight against it porn
would not be as big as it is if people
didn't consume it
this is what i keep trying to tell the
world society
hasn't accepted adult entertainers yet
and it really limits what i can do with
my future
um i'm a violinist and it was part of my
life goals to conduct a high school
orchestra one day
i can't do that anymore that is
sacrifice that is gone
the next job interview i go for after
this
i might not get it just because the fact
that my needs are on the internet
how is the topic of consent handled on
set very important oh i love this
question thank you for asking that
question
earlier on porn was not about consent we
didn't have these regimen and rules that
we have today people would just show up
have sex if the girl didn't want to do
anal
tough you're doing anal i mean there's
been lots of that happening
so that doesn't happen as much anymore
when you're on set there's like a
checklist of like what you agree to do
and like you talk with it with the
director and your partner
consent is like my favorite thing and i
think it's it's hot like
one of my scenes the other day like the
guy was like can i do this to your
vagina and i was like can i do this to
your penis
i get asked to do a lot of really really
bizarre outrageous things the list is
just a mile long
role play involving race or
rape play i'm not comfortable with that
i got a lot of
requests for custom orders from white
supremacists
i practice a philosophy called
enthusiastic consent so unless if i'm
absolutely
enthusiastic to post it i do not create
it
where boundaries were maybe crossed for
you um
definitely and i think like i played a
part in that mostly because i wasn't
aware of how to like articulate my
boundaries or
wasn't aware of what my boundaries were
i would just like agree to everything
without like asking
what that entails yeah i was
and i felt like it was a setup and the
crazy thing was i was excited to shoot
for that company because they're one of
the biggest companies on pornhub
and i felt really comfortable i'm like
okay the makeup artist is here
this other assistant she's here usually
when there's a woman on set i really let
my guard down
and me and the director we started
taking photos and
i noticed the house got quiet and i
asked the director i was like where are
the two women he was like oh they left
and when me and him started filming
he was so rough and
i am i am a victim of rape
so like the things that he was
doing my body just like shut down and
it was just so painful having sex with
him by the time i got home
i was just i was just so tired and
exhausted
and i locked myself in my room for like
two days
because i couldn't believe what i had
gone through
do you ever worry about the way the porn
industry portrays sex
yes the biggest critique i have about
the porn industry
is it lacks any sense of intimacy any
sense of realness
this may be an unpopular opinion but i
think that
tube sites are a bad thing the free porn
world
is putting out scenes and
it's so easy for children to just get on
these sites
and to learn from porn scenes
just for me as a performer i really
wanted to see more realistic sex
instead of something like my name's
tiffany and then like
anal sex ensues you know like like it's
a fantasy and not
realistic you don't see the behind the
scenes the discussion between
the scene partners and i wish um
us as porn stars like we would be more
open and tell people like hey
we gave consent for this it's not okay
to pick up a random girl
at a bar and spit in her mouth and slap
her
i feel in straight porn it's a lot more
aggressive
the woman is like always submissive and
i just like that's rooted in so much
like
hatred for women and like misogyny like
a woman has to do what the man wants and
like make him feel good
i think the porn industry is becoming a
lot more diversified now and i'm really
excited to see
how platforms like only fans adds a
sense of realness back into adult
material
we're producing for you the consumer who
wants to watch it we are in no way
wanting children to watch it we don't
even think it's sex ed
it's a fantasy it's fun so for me my
work has always been
activism and so really putting it out
there and saying look i enjoy my life i
enjoy sex people enjoy watching me have
sex it's a consensual thing between
adults who are having a great time
and giving it to you to watch to have a
great time too i don't worry about it
but i do think the more we talk about it
it will be less stigmatized
[Music]
you